2023 was the year that
artificial intelligence burst
into public consciousness,
stoking the imaginations of many
and the fears of many others.
In 2024, Goldman Sachs says generative
AI will move from an excitement phase
to a deployment phase.
And in the next ten years
could raise global GDP by as much as 7%.
I was delighted to be able to sit down
with a fascinating
and brilliant entrepreneur
who has been at the forefront of
AI for more than a decade.
Mostafa Soliman was a co-founder
of DeepMind.
His most recent venture
is Inflection
AI, which he co-founded in 2022.
What gets you interested
in artificial intelligence?
Well,
I've always been obsessed
with the idea
that tools and invention
are going to make us
more capable as a species.
And that's been the history
of human civilization.
We've invented things
in order to make our lives
easier and happier and healthier
and from a kind of
social impact perspective.
That's the grand offering of science.
You know,
if we look back over the centuries,
our lives have got radically,
radically better.
And that's real cause to be optimistic.
This engine of discovery and creation
is fundamental
to who we are
as a species of curiosity
drives us to create and do more with less
and that's
actually what drew me to
AI in the first place.
So most people,
I understand,
get the AI to do something specific.
Let's say
look at a legal document
and find all the cases that relate to
or look at an x ray and figure out
compared to all the other x rays.
Does this one have cancerous cells?
Help us understand generative
AI, which is the ability of the machine
to teach itself to think
and then to go beyond that
to thinking kind of even more complex
and creative ways
than even human beings might be able to.
So think about it
as two sides of the same A.I. coin.
For the last decade,
we've been focused on classification.
How can we train deep
neural networks to identify
patterns in data?
And it's done that so well
that it can transcribe speech,
for example,
or it can understand
the content of images.
And that's been
the classification revolution.
The flip side of that is if the
AI now understands
the difference between cats
and dogs and zebras in an image,
you can then say
generate me a new example of a zebra
that's never been seen
with the color purple
and with bright blue wings, for example,
because it understands those concepts
well enough
from having seen the historical patterns.
Now, the third
phase of AI that's coming
is interactive AI.
Now that you can have an AI generate
a new example,
it can present that to a human
for feedback
and interact
in order to learn from the human
and be useful to you.
Carry out new tasks In time.
It will learn to use tools,
so it will actually be able
to make phone calls
to other humans on your behalf.
Let me just get an example out
so people understand.
Correct me if I'm wrong,
but I think what you're saying is
you should be able to have an AI that you
say to your phone.
Can you do the following for me?
Two weeks from now,
I want to take a trip to London.
Can you get me a ticket, book me a hotel.
I want to go to this restaurant,
make me the reservation.
And I also need these three books.
Can you order them?
And the AI will then take it.
Take care of it. All right. Exactly.
Think of AIS in the future
as personal assistants.
Everybody is going to have
a conversational interface,
which not just represents you
and is there to help you and support you,
but can also teach you
is actually going to help you day to day
to be better at your job, to,
you know, make important life decisions
when you're thinking about whether
to relocate to a different city
or whether it might be time
to put your elderly parents
into a care home
or whether to go ahead
and have a serious operation
that you're thinking about.
So that gets to a very interesting point,
which is emotional intelligence.
We've often thought that, you know, the
AI will do the analytic part,
but human beings have this special thing,
emotional intelligence, IQ,
social skills.
You're saying the A.I.
can have all that as well?
That's exactly right.
I mean,
we have developed
at my new company,
Inflection, and I called Pie,
which stands for Personal Intelligence.
And we've specifically conditioned it
to be good at emotional intelligence.
It's a great listener.
It's very evenhanded.
It presents both sides of an argument.
It asks you great questions.
It tries to remember what you've said
in the past.
It'll often paraphrase
what you've said in order
to make you feel heard.
So these
sort of
elements of empathy
are actually quite learnable by the
AI and will be incredibly valuable
to millions and millions of people
to have the comfort and support
of a friend, a companion,
an emotional intelligence in your pocket.
I mean, I think people underrate
how significant that is in the world.
Not all of us
have a supportive parent or husband
or wife or child or friend
to help you get through difficult times.
And now that it's going
to be widely available
to hundreds of millions of people
over the next few years,
how do we stay in charge?
That's the key question.
And I think in the limit, it's
definitely possible
that we may not be in charge
and we have to confront that reality
that isn't desirable.
It's not what we want.
We don't want AIS
that have autonomy in our world.
They shouldn't have rights,
as some people have proposed.
We don't want new digital citizens
hanging around in our everyday society.
Just so that people understand
technically.
Is it possible to say, Is it as simple
as saying,
Look, at the end of the day,
you can always have a kill switch
and you can pull the plug?
Or is it more complicated than that?
Yes, it's
going to be possible to do that,
I believe,
if we focus on it
as a research community,
as a group of governing
actors, as creators
of the technology in the open source
and in the private companies,
we have to make that a priority.
We have overcome
huge scientific and engineering feats
to contain nuclear power,
to get the best out of aviation
and not have planes fall out of the sky
all the time to regulate cars
and make sure that everybody
is trained to drive a car
and that there are,
you know,
airbags and windscreens
and vehicle emissions and traffic lights.
And, you know,
these are important moments
in the history of the development
of our technology
where we've really paid attention.
And this is another one of those moments.
The good news
is that over the last decade,
as the models have got bigger,
they've actually got easier to control.
There are fewer hallucinations
than they have ever been.
There are fewer biases
than they've ever been.
And with each
order of magnitude of computation
that we add to these training runs,
what we see
is that they make fewer mistakes,
they're easier to control,
and they take instruction more closely.
And so the real question becomes
whose instruction and what instruction?
What is the behavior policy
that we're asking these
guys to adhere to?
And who is auditing and verifying
that the
AIS are behaving
within the boundary
constraints that have been set for it?
Tell me when when you look
at the future of A.I.,
do you worry about something that
Henry Kissinger and Eric
Schmidt have written a lot about,
which is that human
beings will really be
in a position
of not understanding the world anymore,
that before the Enlightenment
we didn't understand the world
and we would
attribute anything
we didn't understand to divine forces.
You know, the sun rose was the sun.
God moved his chariot across the sky.
We will be in a situation where the
the eye will tell us, you know,
this this, this is the answer.
This is
this person has canceled this book,
but we won't be able to understand why,
because the level of computation
and analysis will be so much greater.
What kind of position does that place
human beings in where we are
almost returning
to a pre enlightenment self
when the in that time
we we looked up to a to God
and now we look up to this black
box called the AI.
But in both cases were believing
not actually understanding.
It's a great point
and it is a real risk
and we can't rest on belief.
We have to rest on reason.
You know, belief is a dangerous path
to being able
to justify actions
on the basis of things
that we can't interpret.
At the same time,
we are all behaviorists today.
We observe outputs.
I don't really understand
what's going on inside your mind.
For example,
I rely on the things that you say
and the things
that you do
to verify that you can repeatedly act
consistently
with your own behavior policy,
your own set of values.
And that's actually how we form
trust in society today.
We don't form trust
by interrogating
the precise causal explanation
of your own data patterns
based on your past personal history.
Now, I'm not saying that we shouldn't
hold AIS
to even higher standards than ourselves,
because clearly we're all in agreement
that we don't want to be,
you know, disintermediated
from our position.
As, you know,
top of the food chain in our
in our species and in civilization today.
But at the same time,
we have to be realistic
about the benefits.
Take health care, for example.
These models are performing
an incredible role
in being able to detect disease at, you
know, human level
performance across the board on radiology
scans for chest x rays, for mammograms,
for acute kidney injury,
for sepsis, for glaucoma.
And you know, blinding eye diseases
and the cost of producing
a world class diagnosis
and the proposed treatment
pathway is about to plummet
to zero marginal cost.
It is going to be essentially free
in the next decade
to provide
an absolutely world class diagnosis
that's going to transform
health care for billions
and billions of people.
And we're going to see
the same trajectory in education.
We'll see the same trajectory
in the development of food
and synthetic materials,
and we'll see the same trajectory
for decision
making and entrepreneurship
across the board.
So the benefits are already incredible.
The challenge is how can we
mitigate those downsides?